hey 42 here if you've ever thought to
yourself that your family's Christmas
traditions were a bit well weird then
you're not alone there are some
incredibly strange legends and customs
surrounding Christmas time and what you
do on Christmas Day can be vastly
different depending on where you live
here are seven of the strangest
Christmas traditions from around the
world Iceland has its fair share of
strange Christmas legends from child
eating cats to growler the troll but one
in particular the you Lutz holds a place
in every Icelandic child's heart in the
past they were seen as mischievous sons
of mountain trolls harassing farmers and
the general population but over time the
you lads became much more benevolent in
the same way that Santa Claus is
portrayed today is a magical stocking
filling bringer of joy on the night
before December the twelve children all
over Iceland would put one of their
shoes out on the windowsill then head to
bed with a smile on their face or a
worried frown if they've misbehaved the
13 new lads would then calm down one by
one on the nights leading up to
Christmas Eve depending on whether the
children had been good or bad the Yule
Lads would leave sweets and presents or
rotten potatoes in their shoes whilst
potato issues were definitely a real
concern for some kids
the Icelandic folk customs Brothers had
to step in and discourage parents from
giving out such extravagant gifts as the
Yule Lads who are seen to be favoring
some kids far more than others the
awareness campaign advise parents for
media and kindergardens
hoping to reduce the festive gap between
rich and poor families the festive
spirit of the euro large remains well
and strong today
perhaps because today they more closely
resemble Santa Claus none the more
sullen image of the morose mountain
trolls that their ancestors from the
1700 possessed
every year in the Cuban town of Remedios
a transformation takes place in the
run-up to Christmas the town splits into
two and the preparation for the puranas
festival begins there is a long-standing
tradition of competition between two
neighborhoods in the town san salvador
represented by a rooster and el carmen
represented by a hawk these two sides of
the town prepare all year to bus let out
for the title of best Christmas festival
this isn't your usual friendly
competition between you and your
neighbor to see who has the most
Christmas lights this is an all-out
battle extravaganza that goes back
centuries not only do the residents
meticulously decorate their houses and
the themes and colors of their district
but each host their own firework show
and float to be presented in the main
display magnificent costumes and dancing
in the streets to a wide Orchestra of
music accompanies two festivities you
would think you're it carnival except
there are Christmas decorations
everywhere instead of samba dancers the
festival finds its roots in the 18th
century when the priest in the grand
Cathedral of Rome EDIUS sent out
children to gather people up for
Christmas Mass the children would have
pots pans and spoons and would run
around the town making noise and singing
songs to attract people and lead them to
the mass over time is developed into the
fantastically extravagant street party
that we see today whilst this isn't
necessarily a strange tradition it's one
of unusual intensity even when compared
to hot spots of Christmas festivities
around Britain and the United States the
festivities are so extravagant and
infectious that nearby Cuban towns host
their own versions with their own
competing districts every year I'm sure
you've had Christmas carolers and
knocking on your door and singing songs
to you before but what about mummers
this bizarre tradition actually has a
few forms across most of Europe but in
Latvia it is particularly well
established and accepted as a local
custom Latvian mumming done by
is a bit like the traditional Christmas
carolers but there's a twist mamas dress
up as all kinds of creatures from wolves
to goats
fortune tellers and bears and other
amazingly surreal costumes they are
usually warmly welcomed into homes as
they are believed to drive away evil
spirits with their costumes dancing and
singing these days it's more of a
festive tradition for good food and good
company
none of superstitious one if you happen
to recognize the voices of any of the
mummer's then they must immediately take
off their masks because of this mummers
usually alter their voices and
mannerisms to avoid being recognized
whilst mumming sometimes adopting
peculiar and eccentric personas in the
ends there's a lot of joyful singing
eating and dancing which adds to the
local festive spirit which is always
nice around Christmas Latvia isn't the
only country where a Christmas tradition
has developed which results in food and
drink for the performers something
similar but with a wackier twist takes
place across villages in southern Wales
Mary Lloyd is a local folk custom that
takes place on Christmas the actual
meaning behind married Lloyd is disputed
to this day some people think it means
gray map referring to the horse head as
well as Lloyd being a common term for
gray others believe it translates to
Holy Mary a key figure in Welsh
Catholicism whatever it means it's
definitely recognizable when it comes to
your village groups of men and women
often dressed in flamboyant costumes
such as puns and Judy would carry the
Mary Lloyd which is a horse's skull on
top of a stick dressed in a frock
through towns whilst playing music they
would travel from house to house and
when they got to your door they would
break out in song asking to be invited
inside is customary to sing back and if
you choose to deny entry with an excuse
this will go back and forth until Eva
the troupe gives up leaving and going to
the next house or the homeowner runs out
of excuses and is obliged to let them in
once inside the tree puts on a
performance where the Mary Lloyd chases
around adults and children alike
snapping its jaws with the leader
attending helplessly to subdue it Marie
Lloyd isn't the only troublemaker in the
troop Eva as punch will even use his
poker to rake out the fire if the
homeowner didn't forbid it before they
entered the house food and drinks will
be served to the troop as Frank's for
their performance and then returned for
their blessing the earliest records of
this bizarre tradition come from the
19th century but the actual origins
aren't clear many finger Mary Lloyd is
an offshoot from pre-christian pagan
rituals involving over hoarded animals
either way it's definitely meant as a
goodwill sentiment but at the same time
it's certainly one of the stranger
Christmas traditions out there because
nothing says Merry Christmas like a
horse's skull Christmas in Venezuela is
a particularly important time of the
year in the heavily Catholic country but
in the capital of Caracas they take it
to a whole new and exciting level for
the pious mourning journey to mass
something which has seemingly developed
out of nowhere is the tradition of
rollerskating to church during the weeks
leading up to Christmas from the 16th to
the 24th of December most roads are
closed until 8 a.m. to allow the skaters
to get to mass safely during this time
you will see streets full of people
skating by with their families because
the children usually go to bed early for
the morning mass they have devised a
cunning way to get up on time some
children will tie string around their
big toe and dangle it from their bedroom
window roller skaters passing by will
and took on the string to wake the
children off personally I prefer to use
an alarm clock to get up in the morning
but I guess getting pulled out of bed by
your big toe is also a viable option
remember that time when you beat a log
with a stick while singing a song to
make it poop out a shiny new bicycle no
well that's what children all over
Catalonia will be doing this Christmas
it sounds bizarre but it's actually an
extremely common tradition that has a
big following in the Catalonian
community it's centered on decorating
and looking after tea Oh dinner doll the
Christmas look the log is actually
pretty adorable when fully decorated
with a painted face a hat and a blank
it with some versions having little
likes that prop it up leading up to
Christmas it's customary to gift here a
little bit of food to eat and cover him
with a blanket to keep him comfortable
and warm the better looked after TOS the
better the presence he is supposed to
provide I say provide but I actually
mean crap out each family has a slightly
different version of the tradition but
generally on Christmas Day
they put tio halfway into the fire and
beat it with sticks to make it defecate
presents no really I'm serious there's
also a very popular song which is sung
during the log beating gift defecation
ceremony parents usually send the kids
out and ask them to pray for good gifts
whilst they beat the log as a nifty way
to sneak presence on the Tio's blanket
whilst they're not looking even though
the way tio is supposed to produce the
presence is a little odd it's still easy
to see the charm of the little wooden
fellow the lyrics to the song are also
pretty interesting to say the least
you probably decorate your Christmas
tree with lights tinsel and baubles but
in Ukraine you might find something
pretty unexpected draped around the tree
it's common for people there to decorate
their trees with fake webs and even
ornamental spiders it might seem like
they are a few months late to Halloween
but there's actually a reason for the
creepy crawlies shenanigans the story
goes that a poor but hard-working Widow
lived in a small hut with her children
one fateful day a pinecone fell to the
earthen floor and took root invigorating
the children with the chance of having a
Christmas tree by winter the children
took care of the tree helping it to grow
but by the time Christmas came around
the poor family didn't have the money to
decorate it so they went to bed on
Christmas Eve with heavy hearts when
they woke up on Christmas Day they were
surprised to find that she was covered
in spider's webs and as they opened the
windows to get a better look at it
the sunlight hits the web's turning them
to silver and gold needless to say the
family never lived in poverty again or
at least that's how the folktale goes
the legend is widely believed as the
origin of putting tinsel on Christmas
trees representing the gold and silver
of the Tron
formed spiderwebs it's amazing to see
just how many different ways people
celebrate Christmas all over the world
some may be stranger than others but all
of them are based on the same universal
Christmas spirit thanks for the view and
Merry Christmas
you